hi I'm Erik Bosse and the vengers
endgame keeps teasing little clues and
new promos it gets pumped it's like they
didn't get the memo that everyone's
already seen this movie but I'm not
complaining because you know me give me
a half second shot of Black Widow and
I'll tell you what time of day it is
based on her haircut we are two weeks
away from the movie's premiere but I
want to dig into this promo footage one
last time because there's actually some
really cool implications of the missable
details in these shots it spoiler
warning in case I get anything to write
in her or not okay this promo is called
mission and let's watch the first clip
in route Ames you know your missions no
mistakes
okay we see most of this footage of past
trailers with the exception of this
quick shot of cat sitting in the seat on
the bow guardianship the benitar it
blasts into hyperspeed the g-forces push
back this poor soldier has never been in
space before folks hopefully his and all
the others faces will get distorted and
warped the way Rockets did when they
ricocheted through space and Guardians -
look at this head time we could use some
laughs
now based on clues that we've gotten in
other trailers and then sneak peeks I
think this mission on the benatar is
part of an early rushed first act
assault on Thanos that might not go all
that well for the Avengers but this
promo actually hints at the later in the
film main plot of endgame with a new
voiceover from cap cap says you know
your teams you know your missions no
mistakes no do-overs whoa okay teams
missions plurals this tells us that
after whatever mission the Avengers
initially go on to go get that son of a
[ __ ] there will also be a separate
strategy in which the Avengers break up
into smaller teams and go on different
missions a divide and conquer strategy
this voice-over also establishes that
the Avengers will only have one attempt
to get these missions right no mistakes
no do-overs kind of sounds a lot like
the Thanos lying to Thor at the begin an
infinity war resurrections the star the
exact details of this complex strategy
remains the biggest mystery of avengers
endgame but everything we know tells us
that it could involve some tech based
solution or an Essene the power of the
quantum realm meddling with timelines
through time travel to past moments in
marvel timeline or splitting into
parallel timelines within a multiverse
or resetting the time loop that they're
already on whatever it is it sounds like
the Avengers will try caps plan first to
lay down their lives to avenge the
Fallen and when that fails they'll try
stark and banners more brainy solution a
turn that would have been foreshadowed
all the way back in the first Avengers
movie you're not the guy to make the
sacrifice play to lay down on a wire or
let the other guy crawl over you I think
I would just cut the wire
always a way out hell yeah there's a way
out Steve this is a comic book movie no
one has to die just change your rules
and now maybe the wire Tony's gonna cut
is the timeline that led to their to
beat here wreath reading it so that it
leads to another future where they win
but who will be on these teams these
missions well the next clip gives us
some more clues look out for each other
this is the fight of our lives
he's pretty good at that right
adventures and gay okay there's
surprisingly a lot here first there's a
relatively new shot we actually saw it
in a past promo
it shows rocket and war machine losing
their footing in the midst of an
explosive attack but if you look closely
right as the explosion starts the
background wall establishes this setting
as Avengers HQ this confirms that there
will be some attack on Avengers HQ
perhaps due to Thanos suddenly having
something to worry about and attempting
to stop the Avengers as they make
progress with all their timeline lately
and it's cap finish this is rally in
speech we see several Avengers once
again wearing these white and red suits
now we've been calling these the quantum
suits or quantum armor because they
resemble the suit Hank Pym wore in the
quantum realm in ant-man the wasp and
some Marvel merchandise as described in
this way presumably these suits will
allow the Avengers to operate in the
quantum realm for however they plan to
violate the laws of physics but notice
Black Widow her hair clock tells us it's
zero red thirty meaning it's sometime
after the opening acts mission more
importantly behind her there's this
curved piece of equipment the kind that
could enclose a space to make an energy
field and I don't think it's a
coincidence that this overhead shot of
them throwing their hands in is framed
to create the visual of a clock so yeah
come on man but whose hands are these
there are nine of them and we know
included in this quantum group are cap
stark Black Widow Hawkeye Scott Lang and
rocket of course the past trailer shot
also included nebula and Rhodey his
quantum suit is thicker more war machine
II so he might be the thicker arm on the
left which might explain the glowing red
light on the midsection or he could be
the more mechanical gauntlet on the arm
in the six o'clock position so that
would make eight leaving one more
mystery avenger in this overhead shot
some are saying the thicker arm could be
Bruce Banner in Hulk form many of us
have theorized before that Bruce Banner
could become the smarter professor Hulk
form from the comics in this movie but
in this shot nah
Hulk's arm and hand would be way bigger
than this remember Black Widows Suns
getting real low palm read kind of a
weird moment but it should burn the
scale of old green banana fingers in
your mind somebody thinking is the ninth
one could be normal banner or maybe Thor
and Hulk is like standing off to the
side like they wouldn't want them in the
fist bump circle because
you can't give a bro tab without
knocking someone comedic Li off-screen
it's just worth noting that not all of
the survivors that we've seen another
shots are present here of for banner and
Carol Danvers at least two of them are
not in this circle maybe Thor and Carol
went off on their own side mission Thor
does like that one and course I should
acknowledge that the Russo brothers have
admitted to using CGI to fake many shots
throughout these trailers and of course
the Infinity Ward trailers had plenty of
shots that work in a final film now
while I think shrinking Hulk's hand
would be too much effort for a trailer
some of these hands must have been
fooled around with because look at this
shot of rocket you can see Scott Lang's
hand on the side there and it has some
device on the back of the palm maybe
it's his Pym tech or maybe it's the
clock-like devices that we saw in their
hands and set photos but then an
overhead shot all of their hands are
bare so foul play I'm just wondering how
this group will divide and conquer into
the teams that cap referred to what are
their missions are there gonna be two
teams of four and five three teams two
three I feel like rocket nebula would
end up on a team maybe to go after the
Power Stone at some other time and
period or timeline and then those set
photos I mentioned suggested stark cap
Scott Lang and Bruce Banner will be on
another team I kind of like the idea
that maybe each of these nine will be
alone team captain II in their own team
of ultimate timeline Avengers guardians
as Guardians kind of like the remedial
chaos theory multiverse episode of
community where each of these nine
timelines is led by the prime POV
protagonist Avenger who has to convince
the others of that timeline to help them
grab the stone does this sound
complicated
yeah whatever it is it's a good thing we
got three hours to process it all folks
in these final days we're likely to see
lots of little shots and TV promos and
hints from the cast when they appear on
talk shows especially if they're repla
so starting now I'm probably gonna lay
low on the daily gossip maybe I'll share
some more final theories and some
reflections on infinity war but then I
plan to unleash hell on you when endgame
finally comes out deal for my thoughts
on general civility and spoilers during
this in game countdown period
follow me on Twitter and you can follow
me on Instagram both at Avis its
subscribed a new rock stars for
everything Marvel and Avengers related
it if you plan to go to VidCon this June
please tweet at VidCon to let them know
that you'd love to see us host a panel a
live show a meet-and-greet we would just
love to hang out with you guys and
grieve together over
whoever tripped on their way out of the
benitar and didn't survive to throw
their hands in for the avenge the fall
in attempt number two we're gonna cry a
lot during this movie but hopefully the
tears will dehydrate our bladders
because of three hours
[Music]